and it is that thing that every time we
see Merl Streep in a film you know it
becomes kind of ridiculous but you you
you are brilliant in the all have you
got performances that you watch back or
remember where you kind of think oh
actually I was a bit pant in that or oh
yeah what what I'm not going to tell you
oh come on oh my god let's guess no
that's
about no you won't guess you won't guess
no I know that's a bad game but but you
won't guess because I've just collected
a lot of awards for that film but I'm
not really so it's one of your big
successes and you think well I wouldn't
say it was s successful it was um
venerated
yeah I'll get it out of them yeah I'll
tell you it was a French tenant woman
yeah
yeah I I really thought but part of it
was in the Str I'm giving myself an out
but part of it it was the structure of
it um was sort of artificial because it
was an act I was the actress playing the
front attendance woman at the same time
I was an American actress playing the
British woman and I hear it now I was
young and new at this and um I just
didn't I I wasn't as pleased as as I
could I didn't feel like I was living it
I didn't feel I
imbued the angel of inspiration with the
whatever it was that's a line from the
movie um but yeah I I we always feel you
always want to do something better after
the fact but you know but there must be
ones also you kind of think nailed
[Laughter]
it who was a uh Drew Barrymore she made
the mistake of giving me notes would how
would you take that I like the way the
lady
runs the lady with my with Mommy's voice